I was in solitary confinement for six
months the best way to describe it you
living in a bathroom I said the best way
to describe be living in the bathroom
with a bed and your desk your toilet and
[Music]
the back of the so you got a window but
the window was all fall get up and like
scratched up like so you can't even see
out the window I feel like my life was
over well I take the rest of your
freedom and they say that's the most
important thing you can take from a
person and like FaceTime because you can
never ever get it back ever can't go
back in time in real answers like my
thing is why lock Somalia why you locked
up Shi kill a spirit even more what's
wrong is with prolonged solitary
confinement the deprivation of social
contact by itself constitutes a sort of
moral suffering that the state is and
has no business inflicting no matter
what the person has done
[Music]
long-term solitary confinement for
juveniles once a rare form of punishment
has become widespread in American jails
and prisons critics say it's cruel and
unusual punishment but many states have
steadfastly refused to end the practice
two cases show the range of offenses
that can put a child in isolation for
months or even years on end
Corey Bauer aged 13 was held in solitary
confinement following his conviction for
several minor crimes the worst of which
was stealing a television from his
school
Michael Kemp was convicted of armed
robbery at age 17 we get Hodgins adult
you automatically go in solitary
confinement and didn't just so many
stories you heard when you're coming up
about jail and adults I sold violent how
I'm saying people get raped in there and
we was young I was smaller than this I
was 150 at the most soaking wet and I
was just like man I might have go ahead
with these adults okay you have 16 year
old show up at your jail your adult jail
and he she mostly he is slight and and
looks young and vulnerable and is young
and vulnerable and so he's gonna go on
the you know into protective custody
so facto it just like night follows day
he was 13 when he was first put in
solitary confinement it wasn't called
solitary confinement it was called
protective custody he was a small kid in
a facility with kids ranging in age from
10 to 21 he had never lived away from
home he had never had never been in a
fight in his life he went into general
prison population in this facility
general population and he became a
target right away so he ended up in
protective custody which was 24 hours a
day in a cell by himself all day every
day you really feel every hour of being
in that cell and you really moving
around in the frame you got files
instead of a door they just like man you
can go stir-crazy in there reading them
books and Portuguese really kept me sane
during that time and I hold because if
it ain't that you you got talk to him
person next to you knock on the wall and
just shot a man has some type of
communication you need some type of
communication with somebody you can go
crazy I still think he's gonna work the
program and come home and even if he
doesn't he'll spend a few months there
and then he'll still come home right
it'll still be fine I don't understand
what I've done or how serious any of
this is until I talked to taco and see
the lawyer and then he's the first one
that tells me the state's adjudicated
your son delinquent he's never coming
home
and he says to me when he's 18 is when
he'll be released and at that point you
might as well buy him a bus ticket to
the Angola State Penitentiary because
that's where all these kids end up and
that's where it's the track they it's
always been your kid just happens to be
a white kid caught up in a system that
was meant to control kids of color back
in the day and that's what the facility
where your son is now is that's where it
started out as as a prison for kids of
color I was looking to find out how many
systems in fact do you solitary
confinement how many juvenile systems
and this is this is not easy information
to get certainly from the states
themselves
it's more numerous than we would like to
think there's evidence that this is
being used in Texas in Florida in
Virginia but we don't really know the
extent to which this may be problematic
it kind of crept up without anybody
noticing
you know these regulations change nobody
understands them very well nobody pays
attention because after all these are
criminals and you know if they're in
prison it must be for something there's
no transparency there's no
accountability in the prison system
nobody sees that except for people like
us and and then we're thought of as like
you know the criminals that raise the
criminals right so why listen to some
mom who's agonizing over our son it's
the kind of attitude that you know that
that makes us all responsible for what
we do to our fellow men and women but we
don't feel responsibility because it's
something that will never happen to us
despite the lack of information about
young people in solitary confinement
last year's report by the Texas Criminal
Justice Coalition hints at the size and
the scope of the practice according to
state records in 2012 thirty six
thousand juveniles were held in solitary
confinement in Texas for an average stay
of six months the most common reasons
for isolation were a failure to attend
school and for their own protection the
expedient of putting them in solitary
confinement for their own protection :
quote seems to me uncalled for because
first most of the time they don't ask
for it and second if they even if they
ask for it it is the prison's burden to
protect them and at the same time don't
inflict cruel inhuman or degrading
treatment on them under the guise of
protection in 2006 a young man called to
recount a story about his time in this
prison with my son and he told about my
son being raped in solitary confinement
by another young person and this young
man was put into his cell by guards and
it was like a wrestling match is what it
was
you know like they took bets on which
kid would win and this other young men
raped my son while the guards just stood
there and egged it on and tried to get
you know saying to my son you need to
fight back you know and calling him a
[ __ ] and that was um that was sort of
this moment where you realized that all
those things you saw and you heard over
the years you didn't escape that and he
didn't escape that that's what happened
to him and that's why he had become so
nervous and anxious and edgy and
had changed I'm a really good kid who
was grieving as the loss of his
grandmother into what society now labels
are criminal and the next witness to
testify his power afternoon chairman
Scott in committee members how I got to
testify before Congress was because I
was white and I look like white
legislators in Louisiana that we needed
to convince to stop doing this to
children and so I got chosen as a
spokesperson we passed the juvenile
justice reform act of 2003 which a lot
of folks in this country called the most
comprehensive piece of criminal justice
reform legislation in 40 years in our
country and we literally drop the number
of kids in state secure care from 2000
to less than 400 where it remains today
we actually changed the way we in
serrated children in our state we need
to ensure that incarceration is used to
punish to deter and to rehabilitate but
not merely to warehouse and to forget
after years of neglect the voices of
parents prisoners psychologists and
civil libertarian groups are starting to
be heard by those in political power
Attorney General Eric Holder amended the
Prison Rape Elimination Act to ensure
that prison employees are screened for
prior sexual abuse and the United States
Senate hearing on solitary confinement
the first of its kind was chaired by
Senator Dick Durbin of Illinois this is
the first ever congressional hearing on
solitary confinement the United States
holds far more prisoners in segregation
or solitary confinement than any other
democratic nation on earth Durbin heard
from experts questioned the director of
federal prisons and even brought in a
replica of an isolation cell onto the
Senate floor
we're seeing an alarming increase in
isolation for those who don't really
need to be there and for many many
vulnerable groups like immigrants
children LGBT inmates supposedly there
for their own protection I thought it
was absolutely terrific that the
Congress and Durbin in particular took
such an interest that has made a big
difference in the in the field in recent
years seven states have either banned or
restricted the use of solitary
confinement for children
despite the prohibitions grace Bauer
believes that a permanent solution
requires greater transparency behind
prison walls we have had laws in place
in this country since the juvenile
justice delinquency and Prevention Act
was passed I believe for the in 1974
until there are more eyes focused on
what goes on behind the walls of prisons
in this country we can never rest so do
I believe the law is the answer
I actually don't the answers are in the
case of protective custody and adult
facilities don't send kids do it kids to
adult facilities period I would say for
example that using it on minors on on
juveniles should always be prohibited
because the
shows very clearly that the effect on
the brain and the mind of of an underage
person is very different than in a than
in an adult and they can never function
productively as citizens again in the in
the real world
Michael Kemp was released from prison in
2008 after living in homeless shelters
he now works with the campaign for Youth
Justice teaching young people to stay
out of prison today he's rebuilding his
life while reading and writing poetry in
Washington DC following his release from
prison
Corey Bower struggled with drug
addiction and the challenges of everyday
life without a work history or job
skills he was finally able to find a job
delivering food for a local restaurant
until this happened he went to the pizza
place where he had been working and
delivering pizzas and he went in with a
BB gun and his friend and he held the
place up and he stole the weekend
deposit bag and drove off the police
picked him up less than a mile away he
got out of the car laid down on the
ground confessed to the entire crime and
asked for mercy for his friend Cory is
currently serving a 12-year prison
sentence for his crime grace Bauer
continues to fight for prison reform
it's not until people tell you about
their child who's been in prison and
what that's been like in their lives and
what it's been like for for their loved
one that I think people it's never
experienced can begin to see really what
the long-term horrific consequences are
of society's taste for punishment
[Music]